varias han sido las reacciones
internacionales desde la publicación de
un video aún no corroborado donde un
presunto soldado ruso decapita un
prisionero de guerra ucraniano
Hay algo en el mundo que nadie puede
ignorar Con qué facilidad matan estas
bestias después de la denuncia del
presidente bolodinski el fmi se
solidarizó con Ucrania antes de comenzar
una reunión con el mandatario la
directiva del organismo guardó Un minuto
de silencio
y resaltó su apoyo hacia kiev con sus
acciones Ucrania se ha ganado un fuerte
apoyo internacional y el fmi se
enorgullece de ser parte de él la
portavoz de la cancillería francesa
catering coloná se sumó también a la ola
de rechazo
ejecutar a un prisionero de guerra es un
crimen de guerra filmar su ejecución es
otro navila mazarrali vocera de la Unión
Europea también hizo saber el malestar
del liderazgo comunitario
Rusia debe cumplir su obligación en
virtud del derecho internacional
humanitario y garantizar que los
prisioneros de guerra reciban un trato
humanitario y en toda clase de
circunstancias de conformidad con los
convenios de Ginebra y que sus vidas no
corran peligro
también rechazó el contenido del vídeo
pero no negó que estuviese implicado el
personal ruso
primero que nada necesitamos verificar
la autenticidad de este vídeo horrible
Por supuesto este vídeo es horrible y
primero debemos verificar su
autenticidad el servicio secreto
ucraniano Investiga los pormenores de la
publicación desde
Moscú el jefe del grupo de mercenarios
Wagner que se encuentra combatiendo en
bahmud negó la implicación de sus
efectivos en el suceso